I want to start with congrats on the
movie and sincerely and I also want to
say that thank you for doing the
screening with us in New York City I'm
looking forward to it
yeah Perry's gonna moderate and I can
tell you that when people when I
announce the screening yeah I can tell
how much interest there is in a movie
based on the responses yeah and we have
way more people asking for tickets than
I absolutely expected wow um in the
first day like a lot of people so the
movie there's a lot of interest in the
film that is really gratifying in here
that's really good to know thanks yeah
because you know you're always worried
that that is the word getting out there
are people interested or are they is it
in sort of engaging people but no we got
Chris and Anna we're we're already ahead
of the Curve
it's a good it's a good start yeah if
I'm being honest I think that's helping
fill the theater
you don't mean it's it's me you thought
it's not me Steve I I think it's a
combination of uh the fact that you'll
be able to watch the movie and anyway
listen yeah so I agree the the the it's
gonna be on the screen it's going to be
great yeah
yeah I
um uh so you early in your career you
did a lot of acting
um and I'm curious if someone and you
still do acting but if someone has never
seen anything you've done as an actor
yeah what is the first what is the first
thing you'd like them watching and why
oh gosh
that's a tough one
ah
I mean I'm trying to get around the
answer by sort of dropping in as many
things as I can most people in the UK
certainly know me from Bugsy Malone
which was a great Musical that excuse me
Alan Barker made with Jody Foster and
Scott Baio many years ago where all the
kids play gangsters
but maybe the Elephant Man I would say
because I was 13 or 14 and I it's a
great incredible film by David Lynch
with John Hurt and Natalie Hopkins
and John gilgood and many other
luminaries so I think but that was
something that really stayed with me as
an experience
and it's it's a great film so if you
just want to whatever it stands the test
of time so if you just want a great film
not I'm a huge part in it I'll Lock
Stock and Two Smoking Barrels how about
go with that I don't know that's it yeah
or revolution without Pacino and maybe I
could go for that or I yeah yeah it's
it's a tricky one that's tricky I was
gonna say that I still can't believe you
did the Bounty and The Long Good Friday
I did a bounty as well yeah I I when I
was 17 I was in Tahiti for nine weeks 10
weeks that was quite yeah with um Mel
Gibson and
Lewis's first film
I think
I know Liam Neeson as well yeah I was
going to say that this is your first
time helming a film with this much
action this kind of scale obviously
you've done Rocket Man and you've done
other things but this is a completely
different Beast what do you wish you
knew at the at the beginning of the
shoot that you learned during the shoot
sort of like the advice you're gonna
give yourself or the lessons you learned
that you'll take with you to the things
you do in the future well I think it's
about the benefits of of previous and
storyboarding which which you know my
other films I didn't really need them so
much before because I could be
accessible enough to all departments
because it's a much tighter unit that
that those Round Table weekly or daily
discussions that I had had with the crew
and and the team I I could help you know
enunciate and hallucinate what my vision
is and is all about and how and how
achieving it is is really
uh in collaboration with those people I
suppose but but you know when I got the
previews for the bus Chase for example
on
on ghosted uh uh I immediately
thought of the piece of music that's on
that and put it on there and so and that
stuck straight away and I'm going to use
it as an example because I think that
and then I didn't have much more time to
do a lot more of that that was one thing
that got the most attention in terms of
pre-visiting stuff which is
pre-visualization you know you kind of
get build assets and build it
so that was a real kind of Revelations
like oh you can kind of really get your
vision across the people in a in a very
succinct and tangible way
really quickly without you know I was
like give that to everybody they all
know then what what we're aiming for
which is great
um so I suppose that but that comes down
to how much prep time you've got and I
I've learned that you know you never
finish you just run out of time on all
aspects of making a film uh kind of like
life really you know
um but but but I suppose so I suppose
that would be something that I'll be
more more mindful of going in going
moving forward hopefully to more action
um
yeah I don't know if that kind of
answers you all because I think this is
this is probably the most important
question I'll ask you um do Emojis count
as a text message
ah
that's a good question
I think they do but I think they do but
I suppose it depends who's receiving the
Emoji or the text they might just be
like yeah that's just an emoji but
emojis can communicate quite a lot
they're a reaction aren't they
um yeah I mean look I'm not you know I'm
not of the generation where ghosting is
really a relevant thing because I'm
married for 25 years and ghosting seems
to be a fairly current phenomena you
know in in the digital age I'm I'm more
analog unfortunately I was in the Bounty
uh for 40 years ago so you know there
was no text messaging then uh there was
dumping then people would say things to
you like it's not me it's not you it's
me or you know I don't see any future in
this now people just ignore you I the
only other thing I can equate you to is
like being an actor as an actor you go
for many many auditions and and you
never find out why you don't get the job
all you know is you you phone up your
agency did I get the job but they say no
you say why and so we don't know why you
just didn't get the job and so that's
the experience of being an actor for
many many years you're constantly
ghosted
um that's the only thing I can I can
make any sort of comparison to
uh uh I do I do I was gonna say I think
emojis do count as a text message okay
well yeah I do I was just gonna say that
one of the things this film does so well
is that it's just a fun movie you know
it's the it's really a really fun film
and talk a little bit about crafting
that tone in the editing room finding
you know what I mean because it's uh you
know because you have a lot of action
you have those fun moments talk a little
bit about putting it all together well
um I I think
what the film
uh benefits from is that the the setup
and certainly for me and for the actors
uh that it needs to feel really genuine
and connected and and
um plausible and and so there's a real
reality to making that work a real
authenticity that the actors have to
bring and we have to craft within that
you know I I in the edit I struggled
with that first initial scene where they
meet for for a long time getting the
tone right getting the the
misunderstanding beats right and just
the the back and forward of it and the
initial attraction that then becomes
something different and and it kind of
needed to feel very real that that
because everyone recognizes meeting
someone they are attracted to for the
first time and having to talk to them
that's an experience probably 99.9 of us
have so I can't cheat we can't cheat in
that moment it has to feel authentic
it's because if it's just too easy
people will go well that's too easy if
it's if it's if it's too contrived and
too high hard then people will pull back
as well so it was getting that balance
right but that created a bar of
authenticity that had to carry through
the rest of the film otherwise the rest
of the film would completely feel
completely inconsistent and so that the
action tries to match the authenticity
of that initial meeting and that
relationship and I think that's where we
benefit and of course it gets
Fantastical of course it is an ax it's a
movie It's Entertainment
but but Chris's reaction always feels
genuine he's scared when people are
blowing things up and driving fast and
shooting guns he's like I just like how
would we react and he'd be like I'd be
terrified I'm like that's what you've
got to do be terrified that's consistent
and and she's a very high achiever who's
used to that world
but can't handle romance can't handle
feelings and that's how she plays so
I think it's a long-winded answer to
what you're asking me I I think that's
it the uh I'm always fascinated about
how things change in the editing room so
what did you learn from any friends and
family screenings or test screenings
that impacted the finished film well I
hate to sound
boast for arrogant or conceited but I'm
gonna run the risk no what what really
happens that when we assembled the film
that we looked at it and I was like and
we we paired everything back for the
director's cut I get 10 weeks to create
the car and was like this really feels
like it's working but of course after 10
weeks of working on watching you get a
bit of snow blindness you know and so we
took it for a test screening
and we were unsure we all go in unsure
you say I think it's good but you don't
know you put it in front of an audience
and it just played so well it just re
people just were a lot laughing at
things that never had expected and then
once that first laugh came
it just sort of snowballed and it
carried on it scored very highly and we
came out of it and the studio said this
is great the score was really good it
was it was a very very positive good
score and we realized that there was no
reshoots or pickups that was done on
this film at all where the film we shot
is the film that people see there's no
pickups no reshoots on it at all there's
one insert of a a ring coming off of a
finger but other than that that's it we
didn't have to go back and and go okay
how do we patch you know and I think the
studio will like overwhelmingly pleased
by that because it means you know
suddenly we'd have to get everything out
on mothballs and employ all these people
again it was like the movie was there
and I think
there's obviously a testament to the
work that was done by all the crew and
cast on the film before when we were
making it we worked really hard to make
the complete film and it was just one of
those rare magic moments where that
actually happened so and so once that
test came in they got like don't touch
it just just don't that's it but I was
like well I'm going to put the visual
effects I'm gonna change some music
know that you know so it's not a million
miles away from the from the film that
was the film that I first cut after my
10 weeks did you end up with a lot of
deleted scenes or not really no no
there's no delete it's there's edited
versions of scenes but there's no scene
that doesn't make it into the end
everything we shot is in the film and
and we didn't there's one scene that I
re-shot because I didn't like it which
was an ending of them driving away in a
car and and I changed it for them being
at the ending that you see in the movie
now but we shot that within the main
body of the film so there's no it's
there's there's great outtakes there's
an outtake reel but there's no extra
scenes that didn't make the final car
there just isn't any it's all in there I
have a ton of other questions but I'm
almost out of time I do want to ask you
do you know what you're going to do next
not not yet there's a there's a couple
of things floating around but I'm I I
want to sort of focus on just seeing
this get out as well as I can but but no
I don't know I'd like to do more stuff
like this I've really enjoyed it and
there's I think I've got more to say and
more to offer on with action I would
like to sort of really
explore that a bit more yeah what's
funny is because I have a lot of
director friends and the the toughest
thing is getting someone to allow you to
make a film on this scale and once
you've done it everyone's like oh he's
done it you can go do it again yeah I'm
kind of interested to see what happens
when this comes out there's a part of
being like well I'm all just sitting
well I mean I feel it's good and people
enjoy it you know I mean it seems to be
and and I've watched it with a couple of
audiences and it gets responses you know
like I say there's no guarantees you
can't take it for granted and and that's
you know a taste is totally subjective
but
I would like to see whether people go oh
that's he has an interesting take this
guy and he can handle it let's see if
there's more more that that comes but
comes across my desk but that's
something for my agent to tell me I'm
gonna wait until this comes out is the
answer yeah um I gotta rap with you I'm
just gonna say I'm very confident you're
going to get offered something else
without action once people see this
um on that note thank you uh great
seeing you uh uh thank you for your time
and seriously I had a blast watching I
really appreciate it thanks